♪Happy Birthday To You
♬～
ハッピーバースデートゥユー
22歳の誕生日を ー
迎えることが出来ました。
２月１４日
はじめしゃちょーです。
実は ー
独りじゃないんです
周りにデュエリストが３人います
ありがとうございます！
（拍手）
わっ
誰だ電話がかかってきてる
はじめ：もしもし
電話：あもしもしー
はじめ：あお疲れさ ー
はじめ：お疲れさまでーす
電話：お疲れー
はじめ：何か僕に言うことありますか～？
電話：誕生日おめでと！
はじめ：わ、ありがとうございます！
電話：２２歳おめでと。
はじめ：ありがとうございます
電話：２５まであっという間で ー
２５から３０までもあっという間ですよ
電話：人生…
まー僕の誕生日は～ ー
ちょっと特殊で、
誕生日の日に、バランタイン・・ディっていう
その、なに
女の子がﾔｧﾔｧ
チョコあげたりﾔｧﾔｧ
なに？
チョコあげたりやれねー
ねぇww
そういう日なんですよ
俺的には
俺の誕生日祝ってほしいのに
なんかそういぅ
バレンタインデイのせいでなんか
俺の誕生日ぶっしょばしてる気がして
なんかその男女比のなんかそういうなに？
男女間のその恋愛もの
的なものに、こ阻まれて
俺の誕生日会がこう薄れてしまってるんで、
まぁこちらとしては非常に悔しい思いをしてるわけなんですよ
バレンタインデイ
許さいぞ！
おい！
バレンタイン！
プロ野球選手の方じゃねぇぞ
バレンタイン
許さないぞ！
お前ら持って来い！
はぃこちらにチョコレート
100枚用意しました
ガーナチョコレートです
誕生日でめでたいのは分かる
まぁバレンタインでめでたいのも分かるけど
俺はそれ雑念を
今日はねぶち壊しに来たのでね
(パシ！)
誕生日だからって俺はそんな
にやにや自分を、
なに？
『おめでとうはじめ』みたいなことしませんよ俺は！
あの～
アレです
“自分に甘く人に厳しk”
違う
“自分に厳しく ー
人に優しく”なんで
俺は自分には厳しくいきます
なんで今日は
こちらの
板チョコ100枚を、
ま瓦割りをしようと思います
100枚一気に。
もうそういうね、なんか
なに？
チョコレートあげてラブラブみたいな
そういう雑念はもういらないんスよ
うちは
アレだ。
やってみたいだけだ
ていうわけで皆さん！
ウッス！
板チョコ100枚 ー
瓦割りしようと思います
準備！
(ﾊﾟｼｯ)
小声「ﾜｧ～」
100枚積み重ねました
ウッス！
ゎｨ～(拍手)
バレンタインのチョコ待ってる男
ウッス！
好きな男に告白したい女子
ウス！
モテない男
ウッス！
全員
堕ちろ
おい！
ちゃんと食うからな
ちゃんとね食べるんで
じゃぁ行くぞ！
ウッス！
周り：ｳ~ｽ
だぁ！
やばっ！
(ｶﾞｼｬｰﾝ)
いた！
( ハッピーバレンタイン )
だぁ！
やばっ！
イッタ！
(最後止め、止めよ)
…ッタ!!
痛!!
絶対無理！絶対無理！絶対無理
イッ…!
僕からの ー
みんなのバレンタインチョコです
周り：「ありがとございます！」はじめ：「食べて下さい」
周り：いただきま～す
周り：どうします？もうちょっと貰ってっても大丈夫っすか？
はじめ：あ～全然
はじめ：もらえないスけど
周り：え？貰ってないんっすか？まだ
はじめ：貰えないよ
コレ貰って、じゃ。(➡)
はじめ：どうぞどうぞ
(ガーナチョコレートの)茶色よりさ、白の方が(甘さ)キツくない？
周り：分かる！
周り：あ～でも僕白好きなんで ー
ー 白処理します。
はじめ：ホントに!?